what's happening is it over
get Alan he would love to do this
how there's any confusion around the
concept that there is no perfect there's
only perfect for you are you on a
journey of really being inside yourself
versus looking at other people's
perceived perfect
[Music]
there's two ways to be Uber successful
deep confidence deep insecurity
my happiness is completely based on
Simplicity are the 12 people that I'm
most infatuated with and love with
healthy
[Music]
I'm driven by the Gratitude of my
perspective and I do want to scale it
[Music]
all of my happiness is predicated on my
humility I don't think I'm special I try
to be great but deep down I don't have
to keep up a facade
content
all of those three things are way
[__] better than a verified account
with tens of millions of followers way
better than tens of millions of dollars
in a bank account way better than any of
that [__]
this concept that we're like trying to
like get validation from others is
really hurting people
I'm trying my best my intent is there
Something's Gonna work and some things
aren't
I'm completely convinced that there's so
much more happiness and simplicity
I am garyvee and we are talking under
understood yep got it yeah I'll give you
what's happening is it over
get Alan he would love to do this
[Music]
you know what let's go to AI disruption
because this is a big topic I think do
you think AI will improve the world of
course AI will improve the world every
technology of significance has improved
the world comma it's not improved
certain parts of the world tractors in
improve the world cars improve the world
if you were the biggest holder of horses
that were sold for transportation cars
did not improve the world if it's good
for you you don't complain about it you
love getting uh Doritos delivered in
five minutes from gopuff but you didn't
think about the guy who lost his job at
7-Eleven because he's not selling it to
you anymore how do you think AI is going
to affect artists should they feel
threatened at all everybody should feel
threatened at all times nobody should be
threatened at any time and what that
means is like you're worried about AI
but you might get hit by a bus tomorrow
this concept that we control life is
laughable if you're such a good artist
you're gonna be okay as if tomorrow
every artist is out of [__] business
I don't think artists should be
concerned I think artists should be
concerned about are they good at selling
their art meaning whether they do it for
nfts or I just mean in general like can
you get a job in an agency all right I
gotta really go I'm so late see ya I'm
good I can I can close out of everything
I'm very excited to have me on the
podcast today Gary welcome to the show
thank you for having me I know you used
to set up signs down Oak Tree Road and
tingly Lane for Lemonade Stand I know
you're used to specifically set them at
a certain height so the drivers would
see them I'm curious what was actually
on those signs that attracted the
drivers what I would be in the car I
would pay attention to other people's
lemonade stand and garage sale signs
looking out the window and I quickly at
like seven or eight knew that like you
couldn't read them most the times so
what the sign would say is 10 cents as
big as you could imagine like literally
the entire sign was like lemonade 10
cents and I would use black marker
multiple times like I knew how to make
it thick and big and simple and at eye
level and then I brought that scale to
the wine store before we got a computer
with a printer we used to make the signs
on the displays by hand and so when I
was at the register when there'd be
downtime I would make the sign regularly
8.99 on sale for 5.99 and I remember
like how different my signs were when I
first got to the liquor store versus
what my dad had like they would take a
regular Sharpie and put 5.99 mine would
be like three times the size of the sign
the 5.99 was like bigger than the
previous sign itself like it was all
that this is a fun interview thank you
for being so prepared they're here all
right I will let you go Gary thank you
thank you absolute pleasure real
pleasure wish you well all right take
care
foreign
[Music]
this is insane I just like Love New York
more than every other City combined
it's incredible
[Music]